[Musique]
à la une de l'actualité de ce 22 mars
l'hommage aux victimes de l'attentât de
toulouse la cérémonie s'est tenue ce
mardi matin à la préfecture des yvelines
à versailles l'enseignant jonathan
sandler qui a grandi dans la ville ses
fils gabriel et arié ainsi que la petite
meryem monsonego ont été assassinés le
19 mars 2012 devant l'école juive ozar
hatorah à toulouse son nom et sasha
cette application fonctionnant avec
l'intelligence artificielle répond à vos
questions sur la santé sexuelle
l'objectif prévenir informer et rassurer
un dispositif lancé par l'association
achète prévention basée à trappes la
présentation de sacha se déroulait ce
matin à paris et puis jusqu'à vendredi
la semaine de l'environnement est au
programme à l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ce rendez-vous
de sensibilisation à une écologie
alternative est proposée par
l'association étudiante 6/4 au programme
ateliers conférences et débats
[Musique]
cvo sans leur stade
parce que leur vie leur champ de
l'ampleur et nos hésitations
jamais il s'appelait jonathan arié
gabriel et myriam ils ont perdu la vie
il ya dix ans dans les attaques
terroristes de toulouse perpétrés en
mars 2012 ce matin la préfecture des
yvelines un hommage leur a été rendu la
médaille de reconnaissance aux victimes
du terrorisme laure a été décerné pour
les familles dix ans c'est tous les
jours 10 ans donc ça change pas beaucoup
mais les gens sont mobilisés oui parce
qu'il y avait toujours comme l'a dit me
lemaire une phrase de émises elle qui
dit que le terroriste ou dure deux fois
la deuxième par l'oubli et c'était moi
j'ai joué j'étais hanté par l'oubli et
donc d'un certain qu'en dans un sens
c'est pour moi un réconfort de voir ces
différencierait 2010 si les victimes ont
perdu la vie dans le sud de la france la
famille sandler est attaché à la cité
royale samuel 100 dollars et président
honoraire de l'association cultuelle
israélite de versailles c'est pas
simplement une mémoire c'est une
fécondité de cette mémoire une force que
l'on tire de ce drame paradoxalement et
grâce au courage de samuel et de mirial
nous prenons tous un peu de ce courage
et de cette force pour développer
fraternité espérances la tragédie qui a
été vécu le 19 mars et bien faut jamais
l'oublier surtout en ce moment où saoulé
la guerre est aux portes de l'europe on
revoit des images d'atrocités il est
essentiel de rappeler que c'est la
concorde entre les hommes que c'est ce
sens à responsabilités qui doit être
mise en avant un moment de recueillement
a aussi eu lieu au square jonathan
sandler inauguré en 2015 sur proposition
de la ville je trouve que c'est
important puisqu'on doit commémorer
puisque c'est quand même les dix ans et
ac les dix ans d'une horreur c'était une
façon aussi témoigné auprès de la
famille sandler on oubliait pas ce qui
s'est passé que dix ans c'est long et
c'est court et comment les a pas oubliés
par un seul jour elle les attentats de
toulouse ont au total fait sept victimes
trois soldats français ont aussi perdu
la vie il m'a dit hatem abdel chez nous
fait mohamed legwand loïc liden littér
lui aussi est grièvement blessé il est
depuis tétraplégique
[Musique]
depuis le 15 mars un site d'accueil pour
les réfugiés ukrainien a ouvert ses
portes à aubergenville il est situé dans
l'ancien centre de convalescence
derrière la clinique de mon gars des 24
personnes ayant fui leur pays en guerre
sont arrivés il ya une semaine le centre
géré par l'association le relais jeunes
des prêts devrait héberger jusqu'à 80
ukrainien à terme un autre centre
d'accueil a été ouvert à montigny le
bretonneux depuis dimanche
[Musique]
petit gros tracas
sacha elle à répondre à des
interrogations sur le préservatif à des
inquiétudes sur la santé sexuelle ou à
des questions sur la sexualité voilà les
missions de sacha une application
conversationnel basé sur l'intelligence
artificielle
le dernier outil proposé par
l'association hf prévention l'idée c'est
vraiment de pouvoir apporter la
prévention au kilomètre zéro dans ta
poche pour pouvoir effectivement donc
discuter avec quelqu'un de ta santé
sexuelle au quotidien on va donc avoir
des phases où on va connecter les
machines vérifier les données à voir des
médecins qui vont retraités ces
informations apporter différentes seuils
de langage et puis ça permettra donc de
pouvoir faire évoluer ce achat sur plus
de 800 thématique aujourd'hui nous avons
permis de développer ce qu'on appelle le
comte sellings donc de dématérialiser
les entretiens que nous faisons
habituellement en face à face avec les
personnes là nous les avons passés en
mode dématérialisation 100000 entretien
de professionnels de santé sexuelle ont
été intégrées à l'application sacha un
travail sur plusieurs années avec
l'entreprise prodigieuse filiale de
publicis groupe j'ai eu un rapport
sexuel et j'ai peur d'être enceinte
c'était un rapport vaginal et ça me fait
peur
sacha en fait va apporter de
l'information complémentaire va apporter
de l'empathie en se rapprochant en
personne en lui disant ok j'ai bien
compris en fait que tu avais peur mais
voilà moi ce que je peux aider à faire
en fait à chaque fois que quelqu'un va
interagir avec sacha on va décider quel
est le message le plus pertinent pour
pour l'accompagner pour lui donner du
conseil mais également pour l'orienter
vers des professionnels de la descente
est disponible sur smartphone sacha peut
être aussi utilisé sur enceinte
connectés l'application sera disponible
aussi sur un site internet sur alexa ou
encore un numéro de téléphone dédié puis
des petits frères de sacha pourrait
aussi naître
[Musique]
il ne restait plus qu elle ou presque or
son vil prix n'est en libye nous encore
adobe ils sont aujourd'hui fibre et
elles font partie des toutes dernières
communes reliées au très haut débit
paris d'une fille on est ravis sur horse
en ville parce que metz a changé notre
vie pour les habitants et pour les
entreprises pour les mairies c'est hyper
important parce que depuis longtemps
nous demande la dématérialisation et
quand on était en adsl c'était pas
terrible terrible et maintenant bas
c'est le jour et la nuit 1 pour
l'instant j'ai que de l'adsl et
c'est pas terrible terrible quoi je
pense que c'est indispensable
et puis moi je fais du télétravail donc
c'est important d'avoir quelque chose
qui va quitter rapidement la fibre moins
d'importance je fais beaucoup
télétravail je suis mais ces gars-là
rythme pour pouvoir travailler dans de
meilleures conditions au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec ces derniers
chantiers plus de 96 % du réseau
yvelines fibre est désormais éligible
une réunion publique était organisée à
paris doivent ils c'est une vraie fierté
parce que c'était pas évident c'est une
vraie fierté parce qu'on est l'un des
premiers départements 100% fibres et sur
les zones rurales et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est important et c'est aussi
porteur d'avenir puisque on a un petit
peu anticiper les mutations les
mouvements avec le co ville on a vu que
beaucoup de mes compatriotes souhaitait
quitter un petit peu là la dig pour
aller à la campagne il souhaite
sauvegarder effectivement cette
proximité avec les entreprises des
câbles étaient encore tiré il ya peu
comme en ce début de mois de mars les
équipes sont sur le terrain objectif du
jour raccordé à un mot amour sont ville
grâce à plusieurs mètres de câbles sous
terre et en hauteur c'est un énorme
travail puisque ont attiré 6000
kilomètres de fibre on a fait plus de
200 km2 de trancher on a fait plus de
1000 chantiers pour réparer des
fourreaux pour changer les poteaux donc
c'est un travail énorme qui demande
énormément de
de moyens humains et puis des temps
machine également extrêmement important
et si je prends le cas de à dainville et
de paray doivent ils ça fait huit mois 9
mois que des équipes travaillent pour
aller chercher ces deux communes la
totalité des communes de rambouillet
territoire est aujourd'hui éligibles
parmi les prochains projets de seine et
yvelines numériques le déploiement des
tablettes dans tous les collèges du
département
voisins le bretonneux c'est la fibre
optique également qui va s'imposer la
ville a été choisie par orange
infrastructures pour un test en 2023 il
n'y aura plus de réseau cuivre pour les
lignes de téléphone fixe et pour les
services internet une expérimentation
qui s'appliquera ensuite sur tout le
territoire français pas de gros travaux
prévus la ville envisage une réunion
publique dans les semaines à venir les
propos recueillis par mélanie poker pour
voisins c'est une chance parce que ça
veut dire que comme nous sommes pilotes
et bien ils vont prendre le temps de
rencontrer les habitants les différentes
problématiques
c'est un petit peu l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir un maximum des cas à résoudre et
donc on aura à l'accompagnement un peu
sur mesure
[Musique]
hybride lé monde de l'université et de
l'entreprise au service du développement
économique et de l'innovation
voici la mission essentielle de x campus
situé à saint germain en laye depuis
septembre 2021 400 salariés techniciens
ingénieurs ou chercheurs de 15
entreprises différentes évolué avec 160
étudiants de siwa et cergy paris
université l'intérêt d'avoir des
étudiants sur le campus est évidemment
pour les entreprises en d'avoir ce
vivier de talents extraordinaires que
sont les étudiants et pour les autres
audiences et leur offrir un
environnement très professionnalisant
puisque on propose aux start up de
proposer régulièrement des
problématiques auxquelles sont
confrontés et et au lieu d'être une
problématique théorique ou d'une
entreprise qui est basée à l'autre bout
de la france bat c'est une problématique
très pratique émises par une entreprise
question de campus donc on peut déjeuner
le midi on peut aller faire du sport
avec la start up qui rend concept
problématique des contrats
d'apprentissage ou de stages seront
également noué entre les start up et les
étudiants hébergés dans le campus à la
jeunesse du projet l'entreprise x blue
dont le campus elle construit autour du
site de cette société de haute
technologie française ça me permet
d'obtenir de vrais talents le développer
aussi et d'orienter les politiques
d'enseignement et de recherche vers nos
besoins qui sont qui sont très forts
parce que nous travaillons dans les
hautes technologies donc on est toujours
à la recherche de vraiment de talent
depuis la rentrée 2000 21 x campus
accueille deux formations de siwa et
cergy paris université dont une école de
design je me suis dit c'est l'école fait
pour moi ce que le campus on a quand
même un cadre assez agréable et puis le
fait d'être avec des entreprises
s'étaient c'était super avantageux x
campus intègre à l'ambition d'un nouveau
quartier universitaire pour la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye situé dans le
secteur ouest de la commune fierté pour
moi c'est de pouvoir construire ce
projet ton puces à l'échelle de deux
villes et comtés d'ici quelques années
5000 étudiants avec ce navire amiral ce
coeur du réacteur quel os x campus en
janvier 2023 de nouveaux bâtiments
seront construits pour accueillir 900
salariés et 870 étudiants en doublant la
surface pour passer à 35 millimètres
carrés
[Musique]
ça c'est un semi d'oignons du coup je
les prix parce que bientôt je vends ma
mère et elle a un petit potager donc je
vais lui donner la semaine de
l'environnement a débuté à l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
après une première journée consacrée aux
mobilités douces rendez vous ce mardi
autour du thème de la fourche à la
fourchette organisatrice de l'événement
l'association étudiante icare occupe son
propre stand qu'on a une distribution de
semis on a des dégustations de jus de
pommes de producteurs locaux on a de la
confiture de lait c'est important parce
que déjà on montre toujours que on est
ici et qu'il ya quand même une vie
associative à la fac et que
que voit là aussi il existe d'autres
associations dans le hall du bâtiment
d'alembert à guyancourt d'autres
associations locales sont venus
sensibiliser les jeunes à leur manière
on a préparé un quizz pour pouvoir
introduire de manière ludique les
activités de terry cité puissance qui
mise et plus généralement sur sur voilà
le travail de l'association on va
discuter un peu de tous ces projets de
comment on peut participer à
l'organisation d'aider ce qu'on aime
dire aussi que c'est un outil pour que
les personnes qui habitent ce territoire
peut s'en saisir pour mener à bien leurs
projets sociaux et écologiques objectif
de la semaine enseigner aux étudiants
qu'il est possible d'agir localement en
faveur de l'écologie déjà aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il ya des personnes là on vient
juste d'installer ville associatif et il
ya déjà des personnes qui nous posent
des questions donc ça veut dire que
quand on est plutôt
confiant et confiante alerté mercredi
une journée sera consacrée à la question
du salariat étudiant jeudi des ateliers
autour de l'éducation populaire et en
prime des conférences tous les soirs de
la semaine
on referme ce journal avec cet événement
j'enfile mes baskets pour les ânes à une
course solidaire et connectée qui se
déroulera du 25 mars au 11 avril c'est
au profit de l'association au fil de
léana l'oea n'a eu qu'une petite
habitante de neauphle le vieux porteuse
d'une maladie génétique rare le principe
réalisé de son côté 5 ou 10 km en
marchant ou en courant seul ou en groupe
entre le 25 mars et le 11 avril
inscriptions de 1 euro par kilomètre
l'argent récolté servira à financer le
matériel médical et paramédical de léana
soutenir aussi d'autres enfants porteurs
de handicap plus d'informations sur la
page facebook de l'association au fil de
léana belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]